you've been asking for it and Blizzard
new you want it but as fate would have
it the latest hero in the overwatch
universe is in fact not doing this
instead the newest addition is a lovely
robot protector known as IRISA my name
is Alisa I'm Luke EPP hey everyone Joey
here and I'm here to walk you through
the basics of the four-legged tank
programmed to protect if she doesn't
seem like a cup of tea feel free to
check out some of the guides for the
other 23 overwatch heroes but if she's
the amna Kube been looking for you've
come to the right place
similar to Reinhardt ERISA is an anchor
tank meaning that your entire team will
typically base their positioning around
where you are now she's got a great
assortment of tools that are similar to
other tanks abilities but they're all
really good at handing off enemies and
deterring their attacks and one of the
ways that she does that is with our main
weapon the fusion driver it's a long
range machine gun that will slow down
ERISA when she shoots
but unlike divas primary fire her ammo
is limited to 150 bullets it's
substantial enough to keep you shooting
for a long time though the damage on
this baby isn't amazing but the fire
rate is fast enough for you to get a
couple head shots in before they can run
away just be careful though because her
reload speed is pretty dang slow so if
you run out of ammo you'll want to take
cover behind the wall or just make your
own wall with our other ability the
protective barrier now if you've ever
longed for a mini Reinhardt shield that
you can launch anywhere well we kind of
already have that with symmetric but
Orissa Shields is just as useful
pressing II will launch a small
projectile and set up a barrier where it
lands packed with 900 HP despite a short
cooldown you could only have one shield
active at a time but it does persist
through death so rest well knowing that
you'll still be protecting your team
even after getting eliminated and if
they manage to break through the barrier
Arisa can still stand strong with their
fortify ability pressing left shift will
turn ERISA all shiny and gold reducing
all damage done to you by 50% for 4
seconds she still has the use of all her
abilities during fortify so feel free to
let loose
but the key mechanic for disability is
that ERISA becomes immune to all
movement and carrying effects so during
those four seconds everything from Mays
Blizzard to Road hogs hook won't do a
thing to her you can even stop a
Reinhardt charge dead in its tracks well
I guess we finally solved that whole
unstoppable force and movable object
thing and even after using fortify if
the enemies still won't get out of the
way ERISA has another ability called
halt pressing right-click shoots out an
orb that looks innocent enough but hit
right click again to detonate it and
it'll act like a mini graviton surge
pulling enemies from behind cover and
slowing them down for a second or two
halt is incredibly effective during
choke points when damage dealers keep
poking their heads out and shooting you
so send it orb their way yank them from
behind cover and focus them down or if
those abilities are tailor-made to help
protect her but her utility won't be
complete without a powerful ultimate
ability to go with it with super charger
ERISA deploys a sweet drum where she
stands boosting everyone's damage by 50%
granted they're in line of sight it's
like having six mercy damaged boots
unfortunately it also has the same
health as mercy which means yes it can
be destroyed so you're going to want to
think about placing it somewhere safe
before activating it one of my favorite
things to do is to put it down right
before a push and then throw a shield
right in front of everyone so everyone
gets the boost but it's also protected
as well
the sheer number of tools Arista has on
hand make her in my opinion an essential
pick on any team offense or defense the
only thing she's truly lacking is any
semblance of mobility option so fast
heroes like tracer or sambar can wreak
havoc on ERISA and coupled with a
relatively low healthful as she only has
400 hit points half of that being
armored you're going to need to play her
smart and safely in order to succeed as
a guardian ERISA isn't meant to protect
so get on out there and be the tank the
world needs hope you guys learned a
thing or two about ERISA
she's shaping up to be one of my
favorite characters to play but let me
know in the comments what you think of
her and don't forget to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and check out all the
other overwatch hero guys as well
[Music]